so I figured that I would work on Silver
City again because I haven't done that
in a very long time and honestly I was
kind of surprised because I expected
loads of reactions like no silver rad
why are you doing this why are you not
working on this Pike but surprisingly I
didn't get that so I was like okay does
it not matter but then again you know I
just do things when I feel like it and I
just didn't feel like building this park
anyway but then there was one morning
and I think this was the last morning of
the test week when I was like okay I
have the urge to build a city hall and
you know that when you have the urge to
build a city all you just need to you
just need to do it you know you just
need to kind of just let your body guide
you to what you really need to build so
that was a city hall so but first I kind
of wanted to do roads of course because
I don't want to place a city on the
middle of nowhere so a plan that I've
been having for a very long time for
this little city here is to actually add
a small park because you know this is
America and we need parks and if we do
make a park i'm just gonna make it
rectangular like that because i don't
know why that just seems to make sense
and i figured i'm gonna place a fountain
in the middle because i don't know why
fans are cool and I place them or you
always blows them in the middle
somewhere and this is going to be that
path that's going to lead on to the city
hall because one of the reasons why I
won at this park there are multiple
reasons of course for one I kind of want
to have a bike because the city without
a park is not a city is it or it's
Detroit and secondly I kind of wanted to
see if I could get a nice spot from
which you can kind of see the skyline
because what's the skyline if you can't
really have a place where you can
actually see it you know that doesn't
really make too much sense be I kind of
wanted to build this park to see if I
could kind of make that skyline look
nice in a distance and stuff like that
and then there's the fact that if I
build a city hall I kind of want to make
it big and neoclassical like I'm
currently doing and this building is
pretty much Washington and all that but
i don't care i felt like building
something like this and yeah that's why
I built the park as well because of you
if you have buildings everywhere and
there's a big city hall in the middle of
nowhere I mean in the middle of the city
with all those kinds of buildings it's
odd you actually get a nice view of it
so unjust designer to build it over here
so I can actually have it park in front
of it and actually look at it from a
distance as well because you
cause you have to kind of appreciate
good architecture from distance I
suppose speaking of good good
architecture this is not going to be the
final version actually delete it half of
this building later on well not half of
this building but the roof I decided to
make the roof a lot lower later on
because that's I suppose that's an issue
with trying to keep the camera at one
place so I carry so I get a good time
lapse it's a problem that you can't
really look at the building from the
side because I was too afraid that and
we kind of ruined the time lapse so in
the end when I did look at the building
from the side when it was all finished I
decided that it looked like [ __ ]
basically and that wasn't all that great
but that was easily fixed by am well I
suppose lowering the roof on the side
and I just hit my pop filter by the way
that's what you hear I always hit my pop
filter because i always make hand
signals and when i'm talking for a lot
to play even though nobody sees it i do
it anyway and then I hit my pop filter
yeah nice to meet you that's that's what
I do in my daily life oh that's of
course that's why I did it I deleted
that wall because it was kind of a out
there over there that didn't really look
too nice I do and then I had to delete
all of the roof stuff and almost back at
square one but yeah this is going to be
the final version of the building yeah
not going to do any more of that messing
around with it and this is also where I
decided okay [ __ ] it i'm just gonna move
around the cat with the camera and
actually get a good building because
that's still more important than getting
a good time lapse and honestly if I do
say so I like this building but then
again a problem that I have with it is
the fact that the theming it's kind of
generic I remember that at one point in
time the neoclassical theme wasn't very
popular in roller coaster game 3 but
then it got popular and just using
Ralphie's uh well antiques at antic
world for new classical buildings and
rarely anything else is kind of well
over done as of lately but then again
this is a city hall and it's in America
so we do need that we do need to kind of
make a building that looks awesome and
like its empower and all that and that's
why this is going to be the city hall
and I remember a couple of other
requests one of which was to build a
cinema I'm still going to try that I
don't really know where to place it
though so that's gonna be a bit of an
issue I also want to try and build a
university well not really a university
is school at least is called probably
just a high school i'm not going to add
anything else surface it's not that big
but yeah I want to build a high school
not an elementary school because nobody
cares about those things and high
schools well sometimes they do have
really nice building so I suppose that's
also something which I can kind of let
my creativity guide me and see whatever
I can come up with which is probably not
going to be all that creative I though I
suppose it's kind of a problem that i
let my creativity be guided by american
stereotypes like over here oh wow that's
a coincidence i decided okay this
building is in America is going to have
to feature loads of American flags
because um you know liberty and all that
so now it has a couple of American flags
I suppose it doesn't really add too much
to the building but you know it's still
random details that you can add and I
can add it because it's America so
that's nice and I suppose the city does
look pretty cool from over here but
that's something to talk about later on
the other thing that I wanted to do with
it with the city hall it's also kind of
at some parks around it I just I didn't
want to have just sidewalks around it of
course I want to have some hedges and
foliage and some nights trees around it
and not really wrote either i don't know
if that's a common thing but basically i
just wanted to have a park next to the
park with a city hall and then the high
school and i'm just going to build one
big place with all the buildings like
that and that's going to be the
high-class area of silver city i suppose
i'm not going to add a slum because on
that that's not too much fun really and
i kind of do want the city to look like
a utopia ish place so there shouldn't be
any terrible places but of course there
are some high-class places and some
middle-class places and nobody cares
about the lower class that's basically
it and
I suppose that civil cities summed up in
one sentence of course with our high
buildings and other stuff of course but
yeah that's beside the point I suppose
that trees really do make buildings look
a lot better because the only problem
that I had with this building as soon as
I built it was the fact that it's just
one big white wall and doesn't really
have too much to it really other than
that but then again adding some big
trees on the side even though it does
kind of block the view I think it really
helps but anyway that's this episode and
see you on the next episode in which I'm
going to do something honey